This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In the 2002 Ram Kham, my big fat Greek wedding, an American woman of Greek ancestry, falls in love with a very vanilla American man. Tulia and Ian's different backgrounds become a parent on one of their very first dates. What do you do for Christmas with your family? My mom makes Roseland.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。在2002年的电影《我的盛大希腊婚礼》中，一位有希腊血统的美国女性爱上了一个非常传统的美国男人。图拉和伊安不同的背景在他们的第一次约会时就显现出来了。你和家人是怎么过圣诞节的？我妈妈做罗斯兰德。
And? And? And? I'm Greek, right? So what happens is, my dad and my uncles, they fight over who gets to eat the lamb brain. And then my aunt Rula forks the eyeball and chases me around with it, trying to get me to eat it,
还有呢？还有呢？还有呢？我是希腊人，对吧？所以发生的事情是，我爸爸和我的叔叔们，他们会为了谁能吃羊脑而争吵。然后我鲁拉阿姨会用叉子叉起眼球，拿着它到处追我，试图让我吃下去，
because it's going to make me smart. Later, Ian invites his girlfriend over to meet his parents. Rodney, didn't you want to have a great receptionist? No, I remember it. She was, just a minute. Oh no, no, she was Armenian. Is Armenia close to Greece? Not exactly.
因为这会让我变得聪明。后来，伊安邀请他的女朋友去见他的父母。罗德尼，你难道不想找一个很棒的前台吗？不，我记得。她只是，等一下。哦不，不，她是亚美尼亚人。亚美尼亚离希腊近吗？不太算。
It's Armenian. Is Armenia close to Greece? Not exactly. The scene plays out a little differently when Tula introduces Ian to her large and very loud extended family. Yes, sorry, everyone, this is Ian. Ian! That's because this is for sure! Tula, bama!
它是亚美尼亚的。亚美尼亚离希腊近吗？不太算。当图拉把伊安介绍给她庞大且非常吵闹的大家庭时，情况就有些不同了。是的，抱歉，各位，这是伊安。伊安！那是因为这绝对是！图拉，巴马！
You know, I've got to tell you, I've never seen my sister so happy. If you heard her, can you make it look like an accident? Because this is Hollywood, Ian and Tula live happily ever after. In real life, navigating relationships of any sort across cultures can be a lot more complicated. Nothing is as good to challenge your own idea that your feelings are natural as moving to another culture. This week on Hidden Brain, how cultural differences are not just a product of different histories and different languages,
你知道，我得告诉你，我从未见我妹妹这么高兴。如果你听到她的声音，你能把它弄得像是一场意外吗？因为这是好莱坞，伊安和图拉从此过上了幸福的生活。在现实生活中，跨文化处理任何类型的关系都要复杂得多。没有什么比搬到另一种文化更能挑战你认为自己的感觉是天经地义的这种想法了。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨文化差异不仅仅是不同历史和不同语言的产物，
not just a product of different histories and different languages, but deep psychological divides in how we feel things. Communicating across cultures can be hard. The potential for misunderstanding always looms. Many of us draw hope, however, from the notion that once we get past surface differences, human beings are the same under the skin. There are deepest feelings, are universal. But is that really true? Bhatia Maskita is a professor of psychology at the University of Lovyn in Belgium. She studies the complex and fascinating world of our emotions. Batia Mosquita, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you very much.
不仅仅是不同历史和不同语言的产物，更是我们在感受事物方式上的深层心理鸿沟。跨文化交流可能很困难。误解的可能性总是若隐若现。然而，我们中的许多人从这样一个观念中汲取希望：一旦我们跨越表面的差异，人类在皮肤之下都是一样的。最深的情感是普遍存在的。但事实真的如此吗？巴蒂亚·马斯基塔是比利时鲁汶大学的心理学教授。她研究我们情感这个复杂而迷人的世界。巴蒂亚·莫斯奎塔，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢。
I'm happy to be here. I'd like to start our chat, Batia, with the conventional model of how psychologists have long thought about emotions. What was that model of emotions that you learned when you were first in graduate school? The model that was really popular was that there was a basic set of emotions. For example, joy and anger and fear. And that we were all born with it.
很高兴来到这里。巴蒂亚，我想从心理学家长期以来对情感的传统模式开始我们的交谈。你刚读研究生时学到的那种情感模型是什么？当时非常流行的模型是存在一组基本的情感。例如，喜悦、愤怒和恐惧。并且我们生来就具备这些。
It was an evolutionary wired ability to have those emotions. And that everybody around the world had them. That really there were these innate basic emotions that everybody had. So in one of your earlier studies, this is at the University of Amsterdam, you asked people about their emotions and many of your study subjects were from the Dutch majority, but you also had volunteers from two minority groups. And you started to see something odd in the data. Can you describe the goals of the study and what you were seeing? I mean, what we originally wanted to know is what the most prevalent translations were of those universal words and so we thought we could find those by asking people to list as many emotion words as they want
这是进化赋予我们拥有这些情感的能力。并且世界上每个人都有这些情感。实际上，确实存在每个人都拥有的这些与生俱来的基本情感。所以在你早期的研究之一，这是在阿姆斯特丹大学进行的，你询问人们关于他们情感的问题，你的许多研究对象是荷兰多数族裔，但你也有来自两个少数族群的志愿者。你开始在数据中看到一些奇怪的东西。你能描述一下这项研究的目标以及你所看到的情况吗？我的意思是，我们最初想知道的是这些通用词汇的最普遍翻译是什么，所以我们认为可以通过让人们列出尽可能多的情感词汇来找到这些翻译
So they listed the Dutch and the Turkish and the Surinameez immigrants list that those emotions, but we found actually a lot of emotions that at that point I didn't consider emotions at all. We found that especially the Turkish and the Surnamees group listed a lot of behaviors, things like crying or laughing or helping or yelling. And we also found that some of the most mentioned emotions in those cultures were not the emotions that we had been taught were universal. So love and hate were very prevalent, but also missing desire, longing. So we found a completely different set of words that people came up with when we asked them to give examples of emotions. them to give examples of emotions.
所以他们列出了荷兰语、土耳其语和苏里南移民列出的那些情感，但我们实际上发现了许多我当时根本不认为是情感的情感。我们发现，特别是土耳其和苏里南族群列出了很多行为，比如哭泣、大笑、帮忙或大喊大叫。我们还发现，在这些文化中被提及最多的一些情感并不是我们被教导认为是普遍的情感。所以爱和恨非常普遍，还有失落、渴望、思念。因此，当我们要求人们给出情感的例子时，人们想出了一套完全不同的词汇。他们给出情感的例子。
Now these answers, especially the answers from the Turkish and Syrian Amis respondents, they didn't fit this model of emotion that in some ways was undergirding your research. What did you do with this problematic data, Baccia? Well, we had lots of explanations, but basically, I'm not proud to say that we thought that people couldn't be right. Emotions were defined as inside feelings. And when people reported behaviors, then clearly they didn't know exactly what emotions were. And so I disregarded them. I mean, I counted them, I listed them, I have a nice table in my PhD that lists them, but really, I never explored the most frequent emotions in those cultures.
现在这些回答，特别是来自土耳其和苏里南受访者的回答，它们不符合这种在某些方面支撑着你研究的情感模型。巴蒂亚，你对这些有问题的的数据做了什么？嗯，我们有很多解释，但基本上，我很羞于承认我们认为人们不可能是对的。情感被定义为内在的感受。当人们报告行为时，很显然他们并不确切知道什么是情感。所以我忽略了它们。我的意思是，我统计了它们，我列出了它们，我的博士论文里有一个漂亮的表格列出了它们，但实际上，我从未探索过这些文化中最频繁的情感。
And I continued looking at, you know, what was the closest translation to anger or to joy. So a few years later, Baccia, you and a Japanese colleague were conducting a study of emotions in Japanese people, and you asked them to rate the intensity of the emotions they felt. Again, when you had given this task to Dutch respondents, it had been relatively simple and straightforward. How do the Japanese individuals in your study respond? Yeah, the Japanese, so this was research that I did with my colleague, my Yumi Kaya Sava, who was in Japan, and we, and she said, they don't understand the question,
我继续研究，你知道的，什么是对愤怒或喜悦最贴切的翻译。所以在几年后，巴蒂亚，你和一个日本同事正在对日本人进行一项情感研究，你让他们评估他们所感受到的情感的强度。同样，当你把这个任务交给荷兰受访者时，它是相对简单直接的。你研究中的日本个体是如何回应的？是的，日本人，所以这是我和我的同事羽生保（音译）一起做的研究，她在日本，我们，她说，他们不理解这个问题，
how intense is your emotion? And so, to be honest, there was a little annoyed, I thought, how can they not understand the question as simple as that? And so we looked for a different translation, and we ended up with a translation that said, how important was the situation for you? And the Japanese were fine with that,
你的情绪有多强烈？所以，说实话，我有点生气，我想，怎么会有人不理解这么简单的问题呢？所以我们寻找了不同的翻译，最后我们得到了一个翻译，上面写着：这种情况对你有多重要？日本人对此没有异议，
but there were also other things that they couldn't answer. We asked, to what extent did the emotion change your beliefs? For example, your beliefs about yourself, or your beliefs about another person, your beliefs about a relationship? your beliefs about another person, your beliefs about a relationship, and that two caused problems. And so there too, we had to replace the feelings, the fact that feelings cause certain things to happen.
但也有其他他们无法回答的问题。我们问，情绪在多大程度上改变了你的信念？例如，你对自己的信念，或者你对另一个人的信念，你对一段关系的信念？你对另一个人的信念，你对一段关系的信念，这两点都造成了问题。所以在那里面，我们也必须替换掉那些感受，即感受导致某些事情发生的这一事实。
We replaced that with deads, your feelings change after this happened, or after the situation. So you started to get some first-hand knowledge of these anomalies when you were in your early 30s. You moved to the United States first to the University of Michigan for postgraduate study and then to a faculty position at Wake Forest University in North Carolina. Now you spoke fluent English and you expected a relatively easy transition. But once you settled in the US, you began to have some odd and puzzling encounters. And not all of these involved unpleasantness, per se, in one case, a professor praised you
我们用“死板”来替代，你的情绪在事情发生后或者在情况发生后改变了。所以你在30岁出头的时候就开始对这些异常现象有了第一手了解。你先是搬到了美国，先是在密歇根大学攻读研究生，后来在北卡罗来纳州的维克森林大学获得教职。当时你英语流利，并期待着一个相对轻松的过渡。但一旦你在美国安顿下来，你就开始有一些奇怪且令人困惑的遭遇。而且并非所有这些都涉及本身就不愉快的事情，在一个例子中，一位教授称赞了你
in front of the class. What did the professor say about you? This was a seminar and emotions. And at that point, I had done a PhD on emotions. And there were all these PhD students who really only started to study emotions and so I introduced myself and you know I said well I'm interested in culture and emotion and he said just want you to know that she came out with the authoritative review of
在全班面前。这位教授对你说了什么？这是一个关于情感的研讨会。当时，我已经获得了情感专业的博士学位。有那么多博士生其实才刚开始研究情感，所以我做了一个自我介绍，你知道的，我说嗯我对文化和情感感兴趣，他说我只想让你知道她写出了关于
emotions she's the world expert on culture and emotions. And I sort of protested inside that expert was a big word and I felt embarrassed and I looked at the grounds. And it was uncomfortable. It was a very uncomfortable interaction between us. But I just wasn't used to people praising me in that way. In other words, you wanted in some ways them to treat you as if you were no better than anybody else, as opposed to someone who was on a pedestal. That's right.
情感的权威综述，她是文化与情感的世界专家。我在心里暗自抗议，专家是个大词，我感到很尴尬，我看着地面。这让人很不舒服。我们之间的一次互动非常不舒服。但我只是不习惯别人那样称赞我。换句话说，在某些方面，你希望他们对待你就像你并不比任何人更好一样，而不是把你捧上高台。没错。
And I would say I come from a culture where that is very much the norm. I remember that if I, if I asked my mom things like was I pretty, she would say, oh, you're just about average. And even if I told people about something that had worked well, about successes, I remember my grandmother saying, commenting that I was tooting my own horn. And that was clearly supposed to be a bad thing. It was not something that was respected or wanted. On another occasion, some American acquaintances you'd met came over for dinner. And at the end of the dinner, they thanked you for a lovely meal.
而且我想说，我来自一个将这视为常态的文化。我记得如果我问我妈妈诸如我是否漂亮之类的问题，她会说，哦，你只是差不多中等水平。甚至如果我告诉别人一些进展顺利的事情，关于成功的事情，我记得我祖母评论说我在自吹自擂。这显然应该是一件坏事。这不是一件受尊敬或被需要的事情。在另一个场合，你遇到的一些美国熟人过来吃晚饭。晚饭结束时，他们感谢你提供了一顿美餐。
What was your reaction to this display of gratitude, but you? My heart sank. I mean, I thought, oh, didn't they like it? Because I thought that it had been very intimate and cozy and that we were starting to feel really like friends. And then when they thanked me for the nice dinner, that to me felt distancing because for me, thinking doesn't happen in a close relationship. In my culture of origin, the Netherlands,
巴蒂亚，你对这种表达感激的行为有什么反应？我的心沉了下去。我的意思是，我想，哦，难道他们不喜欢吗？因为我认为这次聚会非常亲密和舒适，而且我们开始真正感觉像朋友了。然后当他们为这顿丰盛的晚餐感谢我时，对我来说这感觉是在拉开距离，因为对我来说，感谢不会发生在亲密的关系中。在我出生的文化中，荷兰，
you don't thank people who are very close. I also, I had, I was married with an American and, you know, he would bring me coffee and I Would not and he would say well you can say thank you and I said I say thank you to the neighbor You know, I didn't say thank you to my own husband bringing me you know Obviously doing something nice to me, but thanking to me gratitude to me men's having some distance And so you know it sounds small to me gratitude to me meant having some distance. And so, you know, it sounds small, but it actually played a big role in how I interpreted
你不会感谢非常亲密的人。我也，我曾与一个美国人结婚，你知道，他会给我拿咖啡，而我不会，他会说，嗯，你可以说谢谢，我说我会对邻居说谢谢，你知道的，我不会对亲自给我拿咖啡的丈夫说谢谢，你知道，显然是为我做了一件好事，但对我来说，感谢意味着保持一些距离。所以，你知道，这听起来是小事，但对我来说，感谢意味着保持一些距离。所以，你知道，这听起来是小事，但它实际上在我是如何解释
emotions in this situation. And for me, gratitude was an emotion that signaled distance in the first time. Bote found herself mystified. She thought of herself as an emotionally-adept person in the Netherlands. She felt she was a skilled navigator of complex social relationships. The prevailing model of psychology suggested that emotions were the same in different countries. But if that was the case, why did she constantly feel like she was out of step. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
这种情境下的情感中扮演了重要角色。对我来说，感激是一种最初暗示距离的情感。巴蒂亚发现自己感到困惑。她认为自己在荷兰是一个情感敏锐的人。她觉得自己是一个复杂的社会关系网中的熟练导航员。普遍的心理学模型表明，不同国家的情感是相同的。但如果是这样的话，为什么她总是觉得自己格格不入呢？你收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。
When psychologists Bhatya Maskeeda moved from her native Netherlands to the United States, she suddenly felt she had become emotionally inept. It wasn't that Bati was having trouble translating universal emotions into a new language. The emotions she felt and the emotions her American interlocutors felt seemed different. Bati, I understand that the Dutch are of forthright people. So in regular conversations, people contradict each other directly. Can you give me some examples of what such a conversation could look like between two friends in the Netherlands? You tell each other when you disagree. You also tell each other that you don't look so good.
当心理学家巴蒂亚·马斯基塔从她的出生地荷兰搬到美国时，她突然觉得自己变得不通人情世故了。并不是巴蒂亚在把普遍的情感翻译成新语言时遇到困难。她所感受到的情感和她的美国对话者所感受到的情感似乎是不同的。巴蒂亚，我听说荷兰人是直言不讳的人。所以在日常对话中，人们会直接反驳对方。你能给我举几个例子，说明荷兰两个朋友之间的这种对话会是什么样子吗？你们在不同意对方时会告诉对方。你们还会告诉对方你看上去气色不太好。
You tell each other, oh, I was really disappointed, but I think I misunderstood you. You can be very opinionated. I don't like this so much. I do like this. And some of the effort is just by leaving off the praise. I also remember telling my master students in North Carolina that I thought something they had written was boring. And they went for my farewell speeches. One of the students said,
你们会告诉对方，哦，我真的很失望，但我想我误解你了。你可以非常有主见。我不太喜欢这个。我确实喜欢这个。而且有些努力只是通过省去赞美来实现的。我还记得在北卡罗来纳州告诉我的硕士生，我认为他们写的东西很无聊。他们去寻找我的告别演讲。其中一个学生说，
says she would be the only professor who would write in the margins. This is boring. And for me, that was a way of taking them seriously and for giving them straight feedback. I think in the context of a supportive relationship they could definitely interpret that, but it's not something, apparently not something that American professors note in the margins of their students' papers. So Eva Hoffman actually in the author also writes about her Polish relatives saying, you know, this dress makes you fat,
说她是唯一一个会在页边空白处写下“这很无聊”的教授。对我来说，这是认真对待他们并向他们提供直接反馈的一种方式。我认为在支持性关系的背景下，他们绝对可以理解这一点，但这不是美国教授在学生论文页边空白处写的东西，显然不是。所以实际上伊娃·霍夫曼这位作家也写到她的波兰亲戚说，你知道，这条裙子让你显得很胖，
I wouldn't wear it. And I could imagine that closeness is being outright with somebody. You say things because you like somebody, because that's a part of being close. Did you have friends and colleagues who let you know that you were sharing your true feelings a bit too freely? Yes, they sure did. I had this really good friend when I just came to Michigan. Michelle Aker was her name and she overheard another friend or colleague asking me if I was available for lunch one day and I said, no, I'm not. And you know, I was looking forward, but that seemed to me the most important
我不会穿它。我可以想象那种亲密感就是对某人直言不讳。你说话是因为你喜欢某人，因为那是亲密的一部分。你有没有朋友和同事让你知道你有点太过于自由地分享你的真实感受了？是的，他们当然有。当我刚来到密歇根时，我有一个非常好的朋友。她叫米歇尔·阿克尔，她无意中听到另一个朋友或同事问我某天是否有空吃午饭，我说，不，我没有。你知道，我很期待，但这对我来说似乎是最重要的
information. So I thought I was just informative and she took me apart and she said, you know, that didn't sound very nice. You could have said, I would love to, but tomorrow I have plans. You, I think, in America put priority on making each other feel well. So you would say, no, I can't. And maybe you would return to it and say, what about another time? But that's people are not, I don't think we're so preoccupied with not making our each other feel bad or you know not letting each other down. So you found that you didn't have a problem only when it came to criticism.
信息。所以我以为我只是提供信息，而她把我拉到一边对我说，你知道，听起来不太好。你可以说，我很想去，但我明天有计划。我认为你在美国优先考虑的是让彼此感觉良好。所以你会说，不，我不能。也许你会回头说，那改天怎么样？但这并不是说人们，我不认为我们如此全神贯注于不让彼此感觉糟糕或者你知道不让彼此失望。所以你发现不仅在面对批评时你遇到了问题。
Some of your compliments also landed the wrong way. You once offered a compliment to Hazel Marcus, a fellow academic. Where were you both when this happened? We were in the ladies bathroom and we were at a conference that she had organized. And, you know, I really liked her. She later became my mentor. But I wanted to express something. I'd seen her really busy. She was organizing this conference and I said, you look really tired. And, you know, that was meant to make a connection.
你的一些赞美也用错了地方。你曾经向同行学者黑泽尔·马库斯提供过赞美。这发生时你们俩在哪里？我们在女洗手间，当时在一个她组织的会议上。而且，你知道，我真的很喜欢她。她后来成为了我的导师。但我想表达一些东西。我看到她真的很忙。她在组织这个会议，我说，你看起来真的很累。而且，你知道，那是为了建立联系。
And she was like startled. And she said, oh, I should refresh my lipstick. And she turned to the mirror and refresh her lipstick. And of course, I tried to correct myself. I said, oh, I didn't mean to say that you look bad. And I really didn't. I really wanted to say that I empathized with her, that I put myself in her shoes and that she had so many people to talk to, so many things to do.
而她吓了一跳。她说，哦，我应该补一下口红。然后她转过身去照镜子补口红。当然，我试图纠正自己。我说，哦，我不是故意说你看起来不好的。我真的不是。我真正想说的是我对她感同身受，我设身处地为她着想，她有那么多的人要交谈，有那么多的事情要做。
It was really meant as a way to connect, but she instead took it as a criticism or as, you know, she wasn't looking great enough, she wasn't looking up for the part. So after a few years of living in the United States, you found yourself having a heart-to-heart chat with another colleague who was also born overseas. Hijung Kim grew up in Korea. Tell me about that conversation, Bajjap. Yeah, we were both married to white Americans at that point. We both taught at American universities. Our English was, my English was better than it is now because I spoke English every day. We were, you know, we celebrated the 4th of July, a memorial day, and we watched the
这本意是作为一种建立联系的方式，但她却把它当作批评，或者认为她看起来不够好，她没有为这个角色做好准备。所以在美国生活了几年后，你发现自己和另一位同样在海外出生的同事进行了心与心的交谈。李贞金在韩国长大。跟我讲讲那次对话吧，巴佳。是的，我们在那个时候都嫁给了白人美国人。我们都在美国大学教书。我们的英语，我的英语比现在好，因为我每天都说英语。我们，你知道的，我们庆祝7月4日、阵亡将士纪念日，我们观看
Rose Bowl. All those we had American kids, but we just didn't feel that our emotions were quite American. So we talked about how emotions may be the last thing to change in an immigrant, that all of those other things, that psychologists actually have studied when they studied immigration and acculturation, that we sort of met, I mean we had accents, but we sort of checked all the boxes of acculturation, but yet we felt emotionally different.
玫瑰碗橄榄球赛。所有这些我们都有美国孩子，但我们只是觉得我们的情感并不完全是美式的。所以我们讨论了情感可能是移民身上最后改变的东西，所有其他那些心理学家在研究移民和文化适应时实际研究过的事情，我们都，我的意思是虽然我们有口音，但我们算是勾选了文化适应的所有方框，然而我们在情感上感觉仍然不同。
As Baccia spent more time in the United States, she found herself playing translator between two cultures. One time her mom came to visit from the Netherlands. When they went to pick up Baccia's son from school one day, the school teacher greeted Bacchia's mom effusively. His teacher told her that it was so great that she was visiting and how wonderful and, you know, she kind of did the embarrassed response that I did in the beginning. So she looked at the floor and she smiled an easily.
随着巴蒂亚在美国待的时间越来越长，她发现自己在两种文化之间扮演着翻译的角色。有一次她妈妈从荷兰来探访。有一天去接巴蒂亚的儿子放学时，学校老师热情地跟巴蒂亚的妈妈打招呼。老师告诉她很高兴她能来探访，是多么的棒，而且，你知道的，她做出了我一开始做出的那种尴尬的反应。所以她看着地板，不安地笑了笑。
And then she said to me, when we drove back, she said to me, that was really fake, wasn't it? And at that point, I didn't think it was fake. It's a different way of being in the world. I thought that the teacher, of course, wanted to make my mom feel good about herself. And I think she made the compliments and she talked to my mom about my son, Oliver. And she said, how wonderful for Oliver that his grandma is visiting.
然后我们在开车回去的时候，她对我说，那真的很假，对吧？当时我不认为那是假的。这是在世界上的另一种生存方式。我认为老师当然是想让我妈妈对她自己感觉良好。我想她赞美了我和我妈妈关于我的儿子奥利弗的事情。她说，奥利弗有奶奶来探访真是太棒了。
And I don't think that was necessarily fake, but it's kind of the energized way in which she talked to my mom. That didn't feel, you know, to a culture where you should just act normal and not, and that would be crazy enough, that to my mom that felt fake. So, one time, Baccia, you and your family went to see this Pixar movie Inside Out, and this movie is all about how our emotions work and how we're supposed to understand our emotions. To the extent you remember, can you tell me the premise of Inside Out? Yeah, the premise of Inside Out is there is this little girl,
我不认为这一定是假的，但这是一种她跟我妈妈说话时的那种充满活力的语气。这让人感觉不到，你知道的，对于一个你只应该表现得正常而不要，而且这就足够疯狂的文化来说，对妈妈来说那感觉很假。所以，有一次，巴佳，你和你的家人去看了一部皮克斯电影《头脑特工队》，这部电影是关于我们的情感是如何运作的以及我们应该如何理解我们的情感。就你所记得的，你能告诉我《头脑特工队》的前提吗？是的，《头脑特工队》的前提是这里有一个小女孩，
a 11-year-old girl, Riley, and five emotions live in her head. They're all in the head quarters at the control panel. Joy, you'll be in charge of the console, keeping Riley happy all day long. And man. So when Joy controls the control, then Riley is exuberant and happy and positive and optimistic, but she also has some other characters. This is anger.
一个11岁的小女孩莱利，有五种情绪住在她脑子里。它们都在控制台的大脑总部。快乐，你将负责控制台，让莱利整天都快乐。还有愤怒。
He will make sure the world knows anger is in control. Like anger, that is red and fiery and often oppositional and she has sad and sad is droopy and blue of course as in feeling blue and slow and the emotions take control. So that's one premise I think. The second premise is that when never an emotion has the control in the headquarters, that's how Riley behaves. So the emotion is activated and takes over and comes from the inside out and determines Riley's emotion, behavior, thoughts, all of those things. So that's another feature. And the other feature of the movie is that everybody
他会确保全世界都知道愤怒在掌控局面。比如愤怒，那是红色且火爆的，通常是对立的，她还有悲伤，悲伤是垂头丧气的，当然就像感到沮丧（feeling blue）时那样是蓝色的，而且很慢，这些情绪接管了控制权。所以这是一个前提，我想。第二个前提是，每当某种情绪在总部获得控制权时，莱利就会那样表现。所以情绪被激活并接管，从内向外产生，决定了莱利的情绪、行为、想法，所有这些事情。所以这是另一个特征。这部电影的另一个特征是每个人
in the movie has the same five emotions. So the Riley's mom and dad also have a joy, and a sadness, and an anger. And they behave very similar. So this is the emotion that's always the same in every person, in every situation, and in the credits, actually, at the end of the movie, it's even clear that also cats and dogs have those emotions, and they are cat and dog shaped, but supposed to be the same emotions. So yeah, there very much is that within us and maybe even within animals, we have these universal emotions that determine our behavior and that come inside out. So these emotions are internal. They are mental in the sense that they are, they live inside our minds and then they affect how we behave and how we feel. But also that they are in some ways unchanging, that the way sadness operates is the way
电影中的每个人都有相同的五种情绪。所以莱利的爸爸妈妈也有一个快乐、一个悲伤和一个愤怒。他们的表现非常相似。所以这就是那种在每个人、每种情况下都始终相同的情感，事实上，在电影结尾的演职员表里，甚至很清楚地表明猫和狗也有这些情感，它们是猫形和狗形的，但被认为是相同的情感。所以，是的，在我们的内心深处，甚至可能在动物体内，我们有这些决定我们行为并由内向外散发出的普遍情感。所以这些情感是内在的。它们是心理层面的，因为它们存在于我们的心智内部，然后它们影响我们的行为和感受。但同时它们在某些方面是不变的，悲伤运作的方式就是
sadness always operates, the way anger operates is the way anger always operates. Talk about that idea that in some ways there was a fixateness, if you will, to these emotions. It's almost regardless of what happens in the world. And so, when she goes to school one morning and her mom and dad say, you know, have a good day, we love you, monkey. Riley can't respond to that because fear and anger are at the control center in headquarters, which is her hat. And so the idea is very much that what determines your emotions or how
悲伤一直运作的方式，愤怒运作的方式就是愤怒一直运作的方式。谈谈那种认为在某些方面这些情绪具有固定性的观点。几乎不管世界上发生什么。所以，当她某天早上去学校，她的爸爸妈妈说，祝你有美好的一天，我们爱你，小猴子。莱利无法对此做出回应，因为恐惧和愤怒在总部的控制中心，也就是她的脑海里。所以这个观点很大程度上是，决定你的情绪或你如何
you act is determined within your hat and is not very much a result of your immediate interaction or immediate environment. So as you came out of the movie theater, you had a chat with your kids about the movie. What did you say? And how did they react about you? My kids were in their late teens and they loved it. And I said to them, well, Riley the protagonist is an American white girl. And her emotions are portrayed the way Western, especially American white people think about their emotions. And you know, I don't think that a movie would have looked the same way, had it been made in Japan or even in some parts of the US. Of course, my kids didn't like that very much. They said that was a spoiled sport, but they... you shouldn't go
行动是由你脑海内部决定的，并不是你的即时互动或即时环境的很大结果。所以当你走电影院时，你和你的孩子聊了这部电影。你说了什么？他们对你有什么反应？我的孩子们处于十几岁的晚期，他们很喜欢这部电影。我对他们说，嗯，主角莱利是一个美国白人女孩。她的情绪被描绘成西方人，尤其是美国白人思考他们情绪的方式。你知道，我认为如果这部电影是在日本甚至是在美国某些地区制作的，它看起来就不会是这个样子的。当然，我的孩子们不太喜欢这样。他们说这是个扫兴鬼，但是你……你不应该
to the movies with a psychologist. That was no fun. But it's a perfect model that movie of how in Western cultures, I think mostly, we think about our emotions and how in fact the fields thought about emotions when I started my PhD as these fixed entities that we're born with, that are innates, that are universal, that are activated and come out in every single situation in the same way, and that drive our expression and our behavior. So I think the movie is certainly good in telling you how important emotions are in our everyday lives.
和心理学家一起去看电影。那一点都不好玩。但这部电影完美地展现了在西方文化中，我认为主要是在西方文化中，我们如何看待我们的情感，以及在我刚开始读博士时，领域内的学者们实际上如何将情感视为我们生来就有的、是与生俱来的、是普遍的、在每一种情况下都以相同方式被激活并表现出来、并驱动我们的表达和行为的固定实体。所以我认为这部电影在告诉你情绪在我们的日常生活中有多么重要方面当然是很好的。
But I also think it's a very cultured view of how emotions are. When we come back, Bhatia realises that the missteps, miscues and miscommunications she was observing and experiencing were not anomalies to be discarded. They were data, and they were trying to show her be discarded, they were data and they were trying to show her that her model of the world of emotions was wrong. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam.
但我也认为这是一种非常带有文化色彩的情感观。当我们回来时，巴蒂亚意识到她所观察到和经历的失误、差错和沟通不畅并不是应该被抛弃的异常现象。它们是数据，它们试图向她展示被抛弃的异常现象，它们是数据，它们试图向她展示她关于情感世界的模型是错误的。你收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。
Psychology's Bhatya Maskeeda is the author of the book Between Us, How Cultures Create Emotions. Her research distinguishes between the model of emotion prominent in western countries and other conceptions of emotions that dominate cultures elsewhere in the world. Bhatya, you say that if the rest of the world was in that Pixar writer's room, as the movie Inside Out was being created, they would come up with a very different movie? Yeah, I think so. I think it might be called Outside In, actually. Yeah, so I think the Inside Out model is a model where emotions are inside the person, primarily feelings inside the person,
心理学家巴蒂亚·马斯基塔是《我们之间：文化如何创造情感》一书的作者。她的研究区分了西方国家突出的情感模型与主导世界其他地方文化的其他情感概念。巴蒂亚，你说如果世界其他地方的人也坐在《头脑特工队》制作过程中的那个皮克斯编剧室里，他们会想出一部非常不同的电影？是的，我想是的。我想它实际上可能会被称为《由外向内》。是的，所以我想《头脑特工队》这个模型是一个情感主要在人内部的模型，主要是人内部的感受，
primarily in the mind and stable as the movie inside out shows you always the same anger. I think the other model is a very different model where the emotion is primarily between people. So I'm responding to somebody, I have emotions because I'm together with other people. Emotions are when people are together. And then emotions are more acts. So it's about what people do and what the social consequences are of emotions, rather
主要在心智中并且是稳定的，正如电影《头脑特工队》所展示的那样，总是那个相同的愤怒。我认为另一个模型是一个非常不同的模型，其中情感主要存在于人与人之间。所以我是在回应某人，我有情感是因为我和其他人在一起。当人们聚在一起时，情感就产生了。然后情感更多的是行为。所以它是关于人们做什么以及情感的社会后果是什么，而不是
than what the feelings are and why you feel that way. And the third one is that emotions are very much shaped by the situation. So it's not so much the essence in your head that take over everything. But in the first place is the situation that determines or that requires how you need to feel and how you need to behave. I'm wondering, Batcha, as you started to see all the ways in which you found yourself out a step with American emotions, whether you thought back to those early studies that you'd conducted.
关于感受是什么以及你为什么会有这种感觉。第三个点是，情感在很大程度上是由情境塑造的。所以它不是你脑海中接管一切的本质。而首先是情境决定了或者要求了你需要有什么样的感受以及你需要有什么样的行为。巴蒂亚，我想知道，当你开始看到所有那些让你发现自己与美国人的情感格格不入的方式时，你是否会回想起你早期进行过的那些研究。
When volunteers, you know, especially from minority backgrounds, didn't come up with the same list of emotions as volunteers from the Dutch majority or what the models predicted, you initially wrote off the Turkish and Syrian Amis volunteers in some ways as anomalies, but here you were in an adopted country finding it hard to read the emotional landscape around you. Did you start to think maybe what I was seeing in these studies, maybe these actually were not anomalies? Yes, it certainly did. Nothing is as good to challenge your own idea that your feelings are natural as moving to another culture. So I
当志愿者们（你知道，特别是少数族裔背景的志愿者）没有像荷兰多数族裔的志愿者那样开出相同的情感清单，或者没有像模型预测的那样时，你最初在某种程度上把土耳其和苏里南志愿者写成是异常现象，但此时你却身处一个收养国，发现很难解读你周围的情感景观。你是否开始认为也许我在这些研究中看到的，也许这些实际上并不是异常现象？是的，确实如此。没有什么比搬到另一种文化更能挑战你认为自己的感觉是天经地义的这种想法了。所以我
started to take those data very seriously and I thought that maybe the Turkish listed relational acts like crying and yelling and laughing rather than feelings inside them. I thought that, maybe this is a different model of emotions. I also thought about the Japanese findings, that if you don't define an emotion primarily as something that is inside you and a thing, a stable thing, then how can you describe the features of that thing? So intensity is really making the emotions a thing that can be qualified. But if you think about emotions as something that is constantly going on between people, then where is the intensity? So the Japanese I think couldn't answer that question because they didn't see emotions as mental
开始非常严肃地对待这些数据，我想也许土耳其人列出的是关系行为，比如哭泣、大喊大叫和大笑，而不是他们内心的感受。我想，也许这是一种不同的情感模型。我也想到了日本人的发现，如果你不把情感主要定义为某种在你内部的东西和一个事物、一个稳定的事物，那么你如何描述那个事物的特征呢？所以强度确实是把情感变成了一个可以被量化的事物。但如果你把情感想象成某种在人与人之间不断发生的事情，那么强度在哪里呢？所以我认为日本人无法回答这个问题，因为他们不把情感视为他们内部作为本质的心智
states inside them that were essences. So yeah, I think I should have taken those findings very seriously from the beginning. So where I first thought that the respondents didn't understand the task or that the translator had messed up, I now think that something in the phenomenon really doesn't translate so well. That is why you couldn't ask particular questions or why respondents didn't understand particular questions and why the translation was not straightforward. It might be useful to take a look at an idea like authenticity and look at how it's different in these two different models of emotion.
状态。所以，是的，我想我应该从一开始就非常严肃地对待这些发现。所以，我最初认为受访者不理解任务或者翻译搞砸了，现在我认为这种现象中的某些东西确实很难翻译。这就是为什么你不能问特定问题，或者为什么受访者不理解特定问题，以及为什么翻译不是那么直接的原因。看一看诸如真实性（authenticity）这样的概念，并看看它在这两种不同的情感模型中是如何不同的，可能会很有用。
Can you talk about how authenticity is really a hallmark of this Western model, its emphasis on authenticity, and how this is seen in the non-Western model of emotions? There is a large tradition of thought in Western psychology that an emotion has to come inside out So that emotions are there and that when you can't express your emotion, which is there and natural That that's bad for you and Freud would have said that you know suppressed emotions come back to haunt you But also modern literature Modern research finds that Westerners, when they suppress certain emotions, they feel in an authentic,
你能谈谈真实性如何真正成为这种西方模型的标志，它对真实性的强调，以及这在非西方的情感模型中是如何被看待的吗？在西方心理学中有一个庞大的思想传统，即情感必须由内向外散发，所以情感是存在的，当你无法表达那种存在且自然的情感时，那对你是不好的，弗洛伊德会说你知道被压抑的情感会回来纠缠你。但也现代文学现代研究发现，当西方人压抑某些情感时，他们会感到不真实，
they get stronger feelings, they have more difficulty establishing relationships with others, and eventually in a lot of sociological work on labor. People have to modify their emotions for the job, suffer from burnout. It's a very real finding and I think we should appreciate it. But it doesn't seem to hold in the same way for a lot of different cultures. So when Asian Americans, for example, and I'm, let me take this as a point to say that when I'm talking about groups, I'm talking about group tendencies, but I'm certainly not wanting to stereotype or suggest that these groups are homogeneous. It's just that we find if we look at a whole group that the tendencies of the group are different and that this comparison allows us to show that there are differences in the
他们会产生更强烈的感受，他们在与他人建立关系时会有更多困难，并且最终在大量关于劳动的社会学研究中。人们必须为工作调整自己的情绪，从而遭受职业倦怠的困扰。这是一个非常真实的发现，我认为我们应该欣赏它。但这似乎不适用于许多不同的文化。因此，例如当亚裔美国人，并且我，让我以此为例说明当我谈论群体时，我谈论的是群体倾向，但我绝不想刻板印象化或暗示这些群体是同质的。只是我们发现如果我们观察整个群体，群体的倾向是不同的，这种比较使我们能够证明
phenomena. So having said that, when we look at Asian Americans and we have them suppress emotions or or Asians, we do not find the same effects. Asian Americans do not have, they actually, if they suppress anger, for example, they also feel less anger mostly. And they actually don't have the cardiac output that suggests that it's stressful for them at all. They think it's a good thing to suppress their anger. And what we also find is that suppressing original emotions or expressing the desired emotions is not at all related to burnout.
现象存在差异。话虽如此，当我们观察亚裔美国人并让他们压抑情绪或亚裔时，我们没有发现相同的影响。亚裔美国人没有，实际上，如果他们压抑愤怒，例如，他们通常也会感受到较少的愤怒。而且他们实际上没有表明这对他们来说压力很大的心输出量。他们认为压抑愤怒是一件好事。我们还发现，压抑原始情绪或表达所需的情绪与职业倦怠完全没有关系。
That it seems to be fine if you don't think of your emotions as things inside you that have to pop out and that are essences that you can't help, it seems to be fine to regulate or adjust your emotions to the situation. So when we talk about people suppressing their emotions, when we say you're bottling up your emotions for example, that model is very much the idea that there is stuff inside of you and you're putting a cap on it and screwing the cap shut and keeping it inside of you and then you run the risk that the bottle is going to explode at some point. Whereas as other models are suggesting that what you do in the world and how you behave
如果你不认为你的情感是必须爆发出来且是你无法控制的本质的内部事物，那么调节或根据情境调整你的情感似乎是没有问题的。所以当我们谈论人们压抑情感时，当我们说你在把情感瓶装化（压抑）时，这个模型在很大程度上就是这样一种观点：你体内有东西，你正在给它盖上盖子，把盖子拧紧并把它留在体内，然后你就会冒着瓶子在某个时刻爆炸的风险。而其他模型则表明你在世界上做什么以及你的行为
in the world, in fact, changes what's happening inside you, what's happening inside you is in fact, malleable. And if you choose in your behavior not to act on those emotions or in fact to act calm when you might want to be angry, in fact, after some time you will start to feel calm. Is that the idea? Mm-hmm. Yeah. Although, you know, even in Western cultures, of course, we can try to see the emotion differently. There are reasons to think that negative emotions do not always have to come out and that that would be fine and that you can re-evaluate the situation.
事实上，在世界上发生的事情会改变你内部发生的事情，你内部发生的事情实际上是可塑的。如果你在行为上选择不对这些情感采取行动，或者实际上在你想生气时表现得冷静，事实上，过了一段时间后你就会开始感到平静。是这个主意吗？嗯-hmm。是的。虽然，你知道，甚至在西方文化中，我们当然也可以尝试以不同的方式看待情绪。有理由认为负面情绪并不总是需要发泄出来，这样做也可以，而且你可以重新评估情况。
But certainly true that we find more of the negative consequences of suppression in Western environments than we find in other environments. I mean, I'm thinking about some of the entertainment options here where people can go to a small room and people can unleash their anger. I think these are called rage rooms, where the idea is that if you have a lot of anger inside you, you can let the anger out and in some ways this is the healthy thing to do. It is the absolute most amazing feeling of the least.
但在西方环境中，我们确实比在其他环境中发现更多压抑带来的负面后果，这绝对是真的。我的意思是，我想到了这里的一些娱乐选择，人们可以去一个房间释放他们的怒火。我想这些被称为发泄屋（rage rooms），其理念是如果你体内有很多愤怒，你可以把愤怒释放出来，在某些方面这是健康的做法。这绝对是获得解脱的、最了不起的感觉。
But that also follows again from the same model, which is that you have this thing inside you and once you let it out, then you're going to be free of it because it's now outside of you as opposed to inside of you. Right. But again, that's very much counter to this other model that suggests that what you actually do on the outside, you know, actually breaking things in a rage room, smashing windows and breaking television sets. In fact, that could have an effect on the emotions that are inside you.
但这同样遵循相同的模型，即你体内有这个东西，一旦你把它放出来，你就会摆脱它，因为它现在在你的外面而不是在你的里面。对。但同样，这与另一种模型大相径庭，该模型表明你在外表上实际做的事情，你知道，实际上在发泄屋里砸碎东西、砸碎窗户和砸碎电视机。事实上，这可能会对你内心的情绪产生影响。
Right. And I just want you to think that you have just encountered a sexist remark or racist remark. And you go in the Rachel and unleash your anger. But the cause of your anger is not gone. And, you know, your anger probably requires negotiating your anger in the world. So I think it's denying a very important part of emotions, which is that it's an evaluation or a reflection of what you think is happening in the world and what you want to do in the world. Right. So in some ways, these are mechanisms that help us
对。我只是想让你想象你刚刚遇到了性别歧视的言论或种族歧视的言论。你去发泄屋释放你的愤怒。但你愤怒的原因并没有消失，而且，你知道，你的愤怒可能需要在世界上谈判解决你的愤怒。所以我认为这是在否认情绪的一个非常重要的部分，即它是对你认为世界上正在发生的事情以及你想在世界上做什么的评估或反思。对。所以在某些方面，这些机制帮助我们
work well with friends, families, acquaintances, perhaps even with enemies, that in some ways it's all connected to the outcomes we want to see in the world. Is that right? That in some ways emotions are basically the channel through which we interact with the world. I think so. I call them often the glue of relationships.
与朋友、家人、熟人甚至可能与敌人相处融洽，在某些方面，这一切都与我们希望在世界上看到的结果相连。是这样吗？在某些方面，情绪基本上是我们与世界互动的渠道。我想是的。我经常称它们为关系的胶水。
Now, I should say that even when people thought that there were a few universal basic emotions, that they also thought emotions were there to help us connect in the world. So that's not unique, I think, to my way of thinking. But what I've come to think is that their functions are not so much, have not so much evolved, however many million years ago, but that they evolve in the specific cultural context in which you grow up. Love, for example, wasn't the same thing. A hundred years ago or two hundred years ago, it doesn't have the same place in multiple cultures.
现在，我应该说，即使在人们认为存在一些普遍的基本情感时，他们也认为情感的存在是为了帮助我们在世界上建立联系。所以，我认为这对我来说并不是独一无二的思考方式。但我渐渐意识到，它们的功能并不是在几百万年前进化而来的，而是在你成长的特定文化背景中进化的。例如，爱并不是一回事。一百年前或二百年前，它在多元文化中并没有占据相同的地位。
It's not necessarily the emotion to base your marriage or your associations on in some cultures, your associations, your connections are so much given that you don't wanna feel too much love, you actually wanna be reserved. So I think it's very dangerous to think that love, as we know it, which is tailored to the kinds of relationships that we have,
在某些文化中，它不一定是奠定你婚姻或交往基础的情感，你的交往和联系是如此自然，以至于你不想感受到太多的爱，你实际上希望保持克制。所以我认为，认为我们所知的那种根据我们所拥有的关系定制的爱，
exist exactly in the same way in other cultures. Now, it's fair to say many scientists see things differently. The argument that emotions really are the same across cultures, rooted in our biology and in our revolutionary history. cultures rooted in our biology and in our revolutionary history. Bati accounters that evolutionists prepare us to experience and express emotion in any number of different ways, depending on the culture into which we are born. The brain wires itself with experience. And throughout our lives, we collect these experiences.
在其他文化中以完全相同的方式存在是非常危险的。现在，公平地说，许多科学家的看法有所不同。这种观点认为，跨文化的情感确实是相同的，根植于我们的生物学和革命历史中。生物学和革命历史根植于我们的文化中。巴蒂（Bati）则认为，进化论者让我们准备好以各种不同的方式体验和表达情感，这取决于我们出生的文化。大脑通过经验进行自我连接。在我们的一生中，我们收集这些经验。
And the brain is really made to live in a large variety of experiences. Some people would say it's our nature to be nurtured. So the brain is there so that we connect with people in the way that is appreciated in our culture and in the way that gives us the highest survival chances in our particular environment. One of the interesting examples that you explore is how parents might interact differently with children depending on how their different conceptions of emotions might work. You say that American parents might socialize their children to feel pride in self-esteem, whereas parents elsewhere might be more inclined to teach that children about, for example,
而且大脑确实是为了生活在各种各样的体验中而设计的。有些人会说，被培育是我们的天性。所以大脑的存在是为了让我们以文化中欣赏的方式与人们建立联系，并以在特定环境中为我们提供最高生存机会的方式与人建立联系。你探讨的一个有趣的例子是，父母如何根据他们对情感的不同观念，与孩子进行不同的互动。你说，美国父母可能会培养孩子对自尊的自豪感，而其他地方的父母可能更倾向于教导孩子，例如，
shame. whereas parents elsewhere might be more inclined to teach that children about, for example, shame? Yeah, that's right. And I would say American parents, including myself, we really want our children to feel good about themselves. We think that if we give them enough love and praise, they come to realize that they're special and unique and they go on to master the world. But that is not a universal goal. So there are cultures in which shame is the right emotions. And parents want their children to feel shame
羞耻感？而其他地方的父母可能更倾向于教导孩子关于羞耻感的东西？是的，没错。我会说，包括我在内的美国父母，真的希望我们的孩子对自己感觉良好。我们认为，如果我们给予他们足够的爱和赞扬，他们就会意识到自己是特别和独一无二的，并继续征服世界。但这并不是一个普遍的目标。有些文化中，羞耻感是正确的情感。父母希望孩子感到羞耻，
because they want to teach them propriety. They want them to take their right position in the social network. And they want them to be humble and different. And so in those cultures, it's much more important to get your child to recognize that they violated the norms, than to get yourself to recognize that they did something good. I should say there that shame is also maybe not exactly the same as what we in Western cultures call shame, because shame is a good, a proper emotion. It's an emotion that parents like in their children. So children
因为他们想教导他们礼仪。他们希望他们在社交网络中占据正确的位置。他们希望他们谦逊而不同。所以在这些文化中，让你的孩子认识到他们违反了规范，比让你自己认识到他们做了好事要重要得多。我应该指出，羞耻感可能也与我们西方文化中所称的羞耻感不完全相同，因为羞耻感是一种好的、得体的情感。这是父母喜欢在孩子身上看到的情感。所以孩子们
get accepted when they show shame, not rejected. And it often gives other people the idea that you had good parents who knew how to raise you. Because in other words, when you tell someone, don't you have any shame? What you're really saying is, haven't you learned how to behave properly? Don't you have the right upbringing? Exactly. How to behave properly? How to behave properly for your role and your position in the social network? A great place to see these different cultures in action, stand up comedy,
在表现出羞耻感时会被接受，而不是被拒绝。它经常给其他人留下这样的印象：你有好父母，他们知道如何抚养你。因为换句话说，当你对某人说，你难道没有一点羞耻心吗？你真正想说的是，你难道没有学会如何得体地举止吗？难道你没有接受过良好的家教吗？正是如此。如何得体地举止？如何为你在社交网络中的角色和地位得体地举止？一个看到这些不同文化在行动中的好地方是单口喜剧，
especially Western comedians whose parents are immigrants. The Canadian comic Russell Peters, whose parents immigrated from India, has a long standing set about the different styles of parenting in Western and immigrant households. Somebody going to get a hurt, real bad. Because Indian parents will beat their kids. You know what I, my theory is, any immigrant parent will beat their kids. If your parents weren't born in the country you live in, they beat your ass when you were growing up, man. God forbid you look stupid in front of Canadians.
尤其是那些父母是移民的西方喜剧演员。加拿大喜剧演员罗素·彼得斯（Russell Peters）的父母从印度移民过来，他有一个关于西方和移民家庭中不同育儿风格的长篇喜剧专场。有人会受到严重的伤害。因为印度父母会揍他们的孩子。你知道吗，我的理论是，任何移民父母都会揍他们的孩子。如果你的父母不是出生在你居住的国家，当你长大的时候，他们就会狠狠地揍你，老兄。上帝保佑，你在加拿大人面前看起来很蠢。
I'd be doing something dumb, I'd be like, hey, don't do that, you look like an idiot. That's for the Canadians to do. But I also think it's a very different relationship. I mean, I think that American parents raised their children to be independent and to go out in the world alone. I think many in many Asian cultures and beyond. Parents raised their child as part of their family networks. So they're not supposed to go out in the world alone. They're supposed to keep the family name high. And in that way, I think the Dutch culture is closer to a lot of Asian cultures. In that, the emotion just plays a completely different role, the emotion of shame or self-confidence in those types of
我会做一些愚蠢的事情，我会想，嘿，别那样做，你看起来像个傻瓜。那是加拿大人该做的事。但我也认为这是一种非常不同的关系。我的意思是，我认为美国父母抚养孩子是为了让他们独立，独自走向世界。我认为在许多亚洲文化及其他文化中，父母将孩子抚养为家庭网络的一部分。所以他们不应该独自走向世界。他们应该保持家族的声誉。从这个意义上说，我认为荷兰文化更接近许多亚洲文化。因为在这些类型的关系中，情感只是扮演了一个完全不同的角色，羞耻感或自信心的情感。在
relationships. And so I think we all raise our children to have the right emotions, but what is right really depends on what we want our children to be and to do in the world. And that can be very different across cultures. But here in some of your early studies, you felt like volunteers were unable to understand the questions you were posing. And I'm wondering now with your, with the model that you have, this new model of how emotions are operating, there's a chert some light on how in some ways, there might be words or language that we use to express emotions that genuinely might be difficult to translate across different cultures?
关系中。所以我认为我们都在抚养孩子以拥有正确的情感，但什么是正确的 realmente 取决于我们希望我们的孩子在世界上成为什么样的人以及做什么。这在不同文化中可能非常不同。但在你的一些早期研究中，你觉得志愿者无法理解你提出的问题。我想知道，现在有了你的模型，这个关于情感如何运作的新模型，它是否阐明了为什么在某些情况下，我们用来表达情感的词语或语言在不同文化之间可能确实很难翻译？
Well, first of all, what people find is that there are very few words that translate in a one-to-one fashion with all the languages in the world. And there's actually this recent study in science where they looked at more than 2500 languages. And they looked at whether they had one-to-one translations for 24 emotion words that exist in English. So anger, love, happy, proud grief for examples. And what they found is that the only word that had an equivalent, a one-to-one corresponding equivalent, in all languages, what's feeling good or good, all the other languages had less correspondence.
首先，人们发现很少有词语能够在世界上所有语言中进行一一对应的翻译。实际上，最近《科学》杂志上有一项研究，他们研究了2500多种语言。他们研究了这些语言是否有英语中存在的24个情感词的一一对应翻译。例如，愤怒、爱、快乐、自豪、悲伤。他们发现，在所有语言中，唯一具有等效、一一对应等效的词是“感觉好”或“好”，所有其他语言的对应性都较差。
So for example, anger and pride occur in that form only in 15% of the languages. Now how is that possible? It's possible because some cultures think that there is not not much difference between anger and sadness. Some cultures think there is not much difference between anger and envy. Cultures also have a different use of words because our words are used in the situation that way we have experienced throughout our lives. Well, to the extent that those lives differ and they do really differ drastically across different cultures, we have different memories attached to those emotion
例如，愤怒和自豪仅在15%的语言中以这种形式出现。这怎么可能？这是可能的，因为有些文化认为愤怒和悲伤之间没有太大区别。有些文化认为愤怒和嫉妒之间没有太大区别。不同文化对词语的使用也不同，因为我们的词语是在我们一生中所经历的情境中使用的。嗯，就这些生活存在差异而言，而且它们在不同文化中确实存在巨大差异，我们在这些情感词上附上了不同的记忆
words. And of course, then we have words that occur in some languages, but not in other languages. we have words that occur in some languages but not in other languages. I understand there's a Dutch word, gazelle, I'm not sure if I'm pronouncing that correctly. What does it mean about you? Okay, it's the word gazelle. And it's a word that refers to the feeling of being connected with other people, being relaxed, being secure, I would say, but that also refers to some of the features of the environment. So sitting around a fireplace inside is Reseller, or having candles is Reseller, or having food is Reseller. So it's that whole combination of things. And when I've told American friends that, you know, this was a situation of
当然，我们也会有一些语言中存在但在其他语言中不存在的词。我们会有一些语言中存在但在其他语言中不存在的词。我听说有一个荷兰语词叫 gezellig，我不确定我发音是否正确。它对你意味着什么？好的，这个词是 gezellig。这个词指的是与其他人建立联系、感到放松、安全的感觉，我想说，但也指的是环境的一些特征。比如坐在室内壁炉旁是 gezellig，或者有蜡烛是 gezellig，或者有食物是 gezellig。所以它是所有这些事物的结合体。当我告诉美国朋友，你知道，这是一个
Gezele, they of course understand that it was Gezele and they find it a nice word. It's a word that captures this situation. I don't think, by the way, that understanding that this one situation can be captured by Gezele is the same as having the emotion category because I don't think it's so easy to apply it to other instances that we would call also Hazellach. But at that dinner party that you organized a long time ago, what you wanted your friends to acknowledge was that this evening was an evening of Gazellach but instead they just said thank you for cooking us a lovely dinner.
Gezellig 的情境时，他们当然明白这是 Gezellig，并且觉得这是一个很好的词。这是一个捕捉这种情境的词。顺便说一句，我不认为理解这一个情境可以被 Gezellig 捕捉到，就等于拥有了情感类别，因为我认为将其应用到我们也会称之为 gezellig 的其他实例中并不是那么容易。但在你很久以前组织的那个晚宴上，你希望你的朋友们承认的是，这个晚上是一个 gezellig 的夜晚，但他们只是说谢谢你为我们做了可口的晚餐。
Exactly right. I didn't expect them to know the word, but I did expect them to express the sentiment. How long do you think it takes to learn the emotional language of another culture about you? Well, that depends on what you mean by learning it. There is research about second language learning and emotions. And you can learn awards, but what people do initially is they learn awards and then attach it to all the experiences they have in their original first culture. It takes much longer and it actually takes living in a culture to be able to connect experiences
完全正确。我没有指望他们知道这个词，但我确实期望他们表达这种情感。你认为学习另一种文化的的情感语言需要多长时间？嗯，这取决于你所说的学习是什么意思。有关于第二语言学习和情感的研究。你可以学习词语，但人们最初做的是学习词语，然后将其附加到他们在最初的第一文化中所拥有的所有经验中。这需要更长的时间，实际上需要生活在一种文化中，才能将新文化中的体验与这种情感世界联系起来。
in a new culture to that emotion world. And so we also know from linguistic research that you can tell a person a word like Hazelach, but then when they see a description of a situation, new description of a situation, they don't know whether the word applies or not. So it takes people to live in a just learning languages in school, as I originally learned English in high school, doesn't teach you emotions in the sense that you know what they feel like and you know when to apply them.
因此，从语言学研究中我们也知道，你可以告诉一个人像 gezellig 这样的词，但当他们看到对情境的描述时，对情境的新描述时，他们不知道这个词是否适用。所以这需要人们去生活——仅仅在学校学习语言，就像我最初在高中学英语一样，并不能教你情感，不会让你知道它们感觉如何以及何时应用它们。
There's also research showing that people, second language learners, continue to prefer their first language if they talk about emotional topics. So they prefer to curse in their original language, they prefer to love in their original language. Many people find that the second language has less emotion than the first language. You know, it's interesting you
还有研究表明，第二语言学习者在谈论情感话题时，继续偏爱他们的第一语言。所以他们更喜欢用原来的语言咒骂，更喜欢用原来的语言去爱。许多人发现第二语言的情感色彩比第一语言少。你知道，很有趣的是，你
mentioned some time ago a useful caveat, which is that it is not the case, of course, that all Nigerians think alike, and all Americans think alike, and all Chinese people think alike, or that all Dutch people are alike. In fact, within these countries, especially large countries, there are probably entirely distinct cultures, the culture of the Bay Area, is probably quite different than the culture of the American South. And so within countries, you can have cultures, but also, even within cities and geographic areas, you can have huge divides between people who live in one neighborhood or another neighborhood, and perhaps even at a more granular level, you can have huge divides between people who live in one neighborhood or another neighborhood, and perhaps even at a more granular level, you can have differences between
不久前提到过一个有用的注意事项，那就是，当然并非所有尼日利亚人都想法一致，所有美国人都想法一致，所有中国人或所有荷兰人都想法一致。事实上，在这些国家内部，特别是大国，可能存在完全不同的文化，湾区的文化可能与美国南部的文化截然不同。因此，在国家内部，你可以拥有不同的文化，而且，甚至在城市和地理区域内部，生活在一个社区或另一个社区的人们之间也可能存在巨大的鸿沟，甚至在更细颗粒度的层面，
communities of people, between families. And in some ways, I think if we were to extrapolate this idea that culture is not just geographically bounded or bounded by national boundaries, should we actually be expanding our notion of how to think about emotions in this way as well? In some ways, do we all carry our own version of emotions within us? And each of us in some ways is calibrating our internal sense of emotions to the context in which we find ourselves? I really think about it that way. Yeah, I think the differences become more obvious when you cross certain, you know,
人群社区之间、家庭之间可能存在差异。在某种程度上，我认为如果我们推断文化不仅仅受地理界限或国家界限束缚的观点，我们实际上是否应该扩大我们对以这种方式思考情感的观念？在某种程度上，我们每个人内心都携带自己的情感版本吗？我们每个人都在某种程度上将内部的情感感觉校准到我们发现自己所处的环境中吗？我确实是这样想的。是的，我认为当你跨越某些特定的边界时，差异变得更加明显，
national or geographical boundaries. But I think, yes, I think families have their own cultures too, religions have their cultures. You could argue that genders have their cultures. I think cross national comparisons are cross regional comparisons sometimes allow you to see contrasts that you might miss when you compare individuals. But I think the difference there is not, there's no
国家或地理边界。但我认为，是的，我认为家庭也有自己的文化，宗教也有自己的文化。你可以争辩说性别也有它们的文化。跨国比较或跨区域比较有时能让你看到在比较个体时可能会错过的对比。但我认为其中的区别并不是，那些差异层次并没有真正发生实质性变化的方式。
principled ways in which those levels of difference really vary. So much of your work, I think, challenges the idea that we can reach harmony and understanding by asserting that deep down we're all alike. In some ways you're making the case that understanding differences is actually crucial. Yes, I think what we're all alike in is that we're human beings who have social lives and things that are important in our social lives and our social relationships, what those things are and which emotions figure in those relationships are very different. And I think that understanding how people's emotions tie to their social context and to what they find important and to how their
你的很多工作，我认为，挑战了这样一种观点，即我们可以通过断言内心深处我们都一样来达成和谐与理解。在某种程度上，你在论证理解差异实际上至关重要。是的，我认为我们都一样的地方在于，我们都是有人类社交生活的人类，这些事情在我们的社交生活和社交关系中非常重要，这些事情是什么以及哪些情感在这些关系中起作用是非常不同的。我认为理解人们的情感如何与其社会背景以及他们认为重要的事情联系起来，以及他们的
social context would response or do respond makes them human. And just assuming that, you know, as I originally did myself, that your own emotions are universal and default, misses out on the specific humanity of people from other backgrounds. So about you right now, you go back and forth between Europe and the United States. And I'm wondering what that's like for you as you switch between these two models, if you will, of emotions. Do you have a little SIM card that you can swap in and out so that you can actually adapt to the local culture?
社会背景将如何或正在如何反应，使他们成为真正的人。如果你只是假设（就像我最初自己做的那样）你自己的情感是普遍的和默认的，就会忽略来自其他背景的人们的具体人性。那么关于你现在，你在欧洲和美国之间来回穿梭。我想知道，当你在这两种情感模型之间切换时，这对你意味着什么？你是不是有一张小SIM卡可以插拔，以便你能够真正适应当地文化？
Yeah, it's a little less sudden and effective than the SIM card because my SIM card can be and Certainly when I first switch they compete a little it takes me a few days or maybe a week to be on the other SIM card and even then I sometimes have I have some moments where I thought oops that was that was the wrong one So there are moments where I clearly am still Dutch, where I'm trying to explain something about my negative emotions that really nobody here wants to hear, or also the other way around when I'm too full of myself
是的，它比SIM卡稍微不那么突然和有效，因为我的SIM卡可以——当然，当我第一次切换时，它们会有点冲突，我需要几天或一周的时间才能切换到另一张SIM卡，即便如此，我有时也会有一些时刻，我想，哎呀，那个——那是错的。所以有些时刻我显然仍然是个荷兰人，我会试图解释一些关于我负面情绪的事情，这里真的没有人想听，或者反过来，在欧洲语境中我过于自满时。
in a European context. Baccia Miscita is a professor of psychology at the University of Lumin and Belgium. She is the author of the book, Between Us, How Cultures, Create Emotions. Bacia, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. This was a pleasure. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
巴西亚·米西塔（Bacia Miscita）是比利时鲁汶大学的心理学教授。她是《在我们之间：文化如何创造情感》（Between Us, How Cultures Create Emotions）一书的作者。巴西亚，非常感谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。非常感谢邀请我。这非常荣幸。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏的大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲·保罗（Annie Murphy-Paul）、克里斯滕·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）和安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。
For today's Enzang Hero, we turn the mic over to you, our listeners. It's a story from our show, My An Sankiro. Today's My An Sankiro is brought to you by Anstar. Onstar advisors are now with you everywhere, on the app, in your car, and at home. Our story comes from Ayanna Thomas. Some years ago Ayanna went to Japan for a conference. She was excited to be there by herself, exploring Tokyo for the first time. Early one morning, on her way to the train station, it started to rain.
今天的英雄，我们把话筒交给你，我们的听众。这是一个来自我们的节目“我的英雄”的故事。今天的“我的英雄”由OnStar赞助。OnStar顾问现在随时随地陪伴着你，在应用程序中、在你的车里以及在家中。我们的故事来自阿扬娜·托马斯（Ayanna Thomas）。几年前，阿扬娜去日本参加一个会议。她很高兴能一个人去那里，第一次探索东京。一天清晨，在她去火车站的路上，天开始下雨。
I didn't have an umbrella and the rain just started dumping on me as I'm walking to the train station. And all of a sudden this man walks up next to me and he just opens his umbrella. And he proceeds to escort me to the train station. This is a Japanese man who doesn't speak any English and I don't speak any Japanese. And we walk in silence to the train stations, maybe a five-minute walk. So he didn't know or had no information for me as to where I was going, but he must have assumed that I was heading back to the train station. He escorted me in, and then I looked at him and I just nodded my head and he nodded back. And he just went back up the stairs and went on his way. What I think is great about that man and why it stuck with me for so many years is that
我没有带伞，当我走向火车站时，雨哗哗地倾盆而下。突然，这个男人走到我旁边，他打开了他的伞。并继续护送我去火车站。这是一个不会说任何英语的日本男人，我也不会说任何日语。我们默默地走向火车站，大概五分钟的步行路程。所以他不知道也没有关于我要去哪里的任何信息，但他一定以为我是要回火车站。他把我护送进去，然后我看着他，我只是点了点头，他也点了点头。然后他走回楼梯上，继续走他的路。我认为那个男人最棒的地方以及为什么他这么多年一直留在我的记忆中，是因为
we didn't exchange any words, but he was so kind to see a stranger that just was in need of some help. And that was it. Iana Thomas. She's a psychologist at Tavts University and a former guest of the show. You can hear our conversation with her on our episode about memory. It's called, Did That Really Happen? This segment was brought to you by OnStar. OnStar believes everyone has the right to feel safe everywhere. That's why their emergency advisors are now available to help not only in the car but wherever you are, on your phone, in your car and at home. On-star, be safe out there.
我们没有交流任何言语，但他非常善良，看到一个陌生人正需要一些帮助。就是这样。阿扬娜·托马斯。她是塔夫茨大学（Tufts University）的心理学家，也是节目的前嘉宾。你可以在我们关于记忆的那期节目中听到我们与她的对话。它叫做《那真的发生过吗？》本片段由OnStar赞助。OnStar坚信每个人都有在任何地方都感到安全的权利。这就是为什么他们的紧急顾问现在不仅在车里，而且无论你在哪里、在你的手机上、在你的车里和家里，都可以随时为你提供帮助。On-star，在外面注意安全。
If you liked this episode and would like us to produce more shows like this, please consider supporting our work. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, if you would like to help support the show you love, go to support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, if you would like to help support the show you love, go to support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢这一集，并希望我们制作更多这样的节目，请考虑支持我们的工作。访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。再说一次，如果你想帮助支持你喜爱的节目，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。再说一次，如果你想帮助支持你喜爱的节目，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。回头见。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。